welcome back to the David Pakman show. It's
great to welcome to the program today. Me
Hall Rose Wore Ski who's an economist trade
union research.
Sure. And also author of the People's Republic
of Walmart, which is a very interesting book,
particularly in two contexts for me. I mean,
one is of course, uh, just generally thinking
about the way, uh, now me hauling in which
socialism is again, sort of part of the discussion,
uh, in the United States in particular, and
about the misunderstanding that exists about
the so-called sort of independence of a lot
of these major corporations from government
support. Um, but also, uh, in light of many
of the recent protests around companies like
Amazon and Walmart specifically. So just to
kind of introduce people who maybe don't,
don't yet know the frame in which you're writing
about Walmart and these big companies, in
what ways do these companies resemble planned
economies?
Yeah, that's a good question. Basically internally,
um, they are sort of miniature plans, a plan
to climb use. And we're not used to thinking
about them that way. We're used to thinking
that we live in the market economy and I,
there's market relationships. You know, you
go to Walmart, you buy something for, uh,
for a price. Um, and you know, when you, and
you exchanged money, the price goes up and
down. Uh, but we forget that the person who
works at Walmart, for example, um, doesn't
go up to their boss and say, you know, um,
I'll stock that shelf for three 50 today,
but maybe $4 a tomorrow. They just get told,
uh, told what to do. And that happens up and
down, up and down. The corporation decisions
are made, uh, you know, based on sort of,
uh, rational, purposeful decision making,
uh, rather than, uh, this sort of blind market
forces.
Uh, so any large, any large corporation really,
you know, we, we use Walmart than an Amazon
because they're, uh, they're large and people
and people know them and they're also, consumers
are facing, um, corporations, which historically
has been, uh, the argument has been that this
is the harder had been the harder thing to
plan, but really, you know, whether it's a
GE or even large public, um, enterprises like
her healthcare system here in Canada or the
NHS in the UK, um, internally really so much
of, um, of our already existing economy is
already planned. So our book really, uh, has
two core ideas. Uh, one is that planning already
exists on the large scale, uh, but the second
is that it's largely a undemocratic, um, authoritarian,
uh, you know, within a Walmart or an Amazon.
Um, and that it could be, uh, done very differently.
So are you, do you make a value judgment about
whether, whether one way or the other is better
for the different parties that are involved?
Or do you take the approach that, hey, without
making a value judgment, we just need to call
things what they are? And the ways in which
a lot of these corporations are functioning
is not the sort of free market, um, supply
and demand driven meme that has been spread.
Yeah, I think, I think it's a bit of, I think
it's a bit of both. And I think that's, um,
I think it's good that you raised both. I
mean, I think an important part of the book
really is just about, uh, calling things,
what they are and using these case studies,
uh, to drill down and to look at, you know,
what really makes a Walmart or Amazon run,
what's, what does even Walmart's relationship
with its suppliers look like, where if you
go into the, you know, uh, we did it so you
don't have to go into the boring operations
research literature and, and all of this,
um, Walmart's relationship with its suppliers
even less than less resembles, uh, a market.
But, uh, what many of the scholars who look
at our call sort of affirm ification. So,
um, integration of suppliers into a sort of
bigger, uh, into a bigger plan built on information
sharing and trust.
So really looking at what, what are these
economic relationships even as they exist
today, even under capitalism where, you know,
we were told, um, you know, after the end
of the Cold War that planning had failed and
it'll, it'll never work low and behold, it's
everywhere around us. Um, but then going,
going further and trying to, uh, try to make
some of those, uh, value judgments or at least
evaluate, you know, what is it about planning
under capitalism that, um, that might be a
limiting of people that might, might be producing,
you know, a lot of exploitation and unfreedom
and all the regular things that we, a lot
of the regular problems that we think of in
our school
talk. Can you talk a little bit about that
relationship that a company like Walmart has
with its suppliers of products? Because this
is actually a super interesting, a entire
other area that's separate from the relationship
with employees, which is that we imagine a
company has a product that they make and want
to sell and they go to Walmart and they say,
here's what we offer the product for wholesale.
Here's what we recommend. You sell it at retail,
can we do business? And it's sort of this
relationship in which both parties have a
relatively similar amounts of sort of negotiating
power and everybody comes away the better,
uh, as a result of it. But these relationships
that, uh, Walmart has with its suppliers are
often quite different from that, aren't they?
Yeah. And I think it's good that you mentioned
power as well. I mean, I think power is really
important here and Walmart has a lot of economic
power, so it is, um, in some ways it's able
to sort of, you know, bludge in its suppliers
and kind of, and squeeze out these low prices
that then, uh, consumers get. But there, um,
squeezing them out. Exactly. Now then that
sort of traditional way that, uh, you know,
quarter by quarter, year after year that will
just make these, uh, these new contracts.
It is, um, it is this kind of extension of
planning down the supply chain, um, to the
level where it's, you know, not, uh, another
way of putting it in the literature in the
literature is often that it's not really as
much pull inflation that consumers, you know,
saying we need, you know, x letting Walmart
determine that they need x balls of shampoo
or whatever, but kind of push inflation where
Walmart and its suppliers are determining,
you know, what will be, um, what will be on
special and based on, based on trends in consumer,
uh, consumer needs and all of that, they're
going to be actually setting, um, sort of
the, the mix of products and, and, and the
amounts and pushing them and pushing them
into stores and to the level where Walmart
will often have these deep relationships with
its suppliers where there might be, uh, the
it systems might be integrated.
There might even be, um, Walmart staff in
some of the, um, in some of the production
facilities. Amazon does something similar
with, uh, with a program called vendor flex
where again, they're, you know, there's actually
employees of Walmart or Amazon at say Johnson
and Johnson or something like that that are
helping sort of set, um, set the parameters
for production itself.
There's this fascinating statistic when we
look at the hundred top global economies where,
uh, if I recall correctly, 69 are actually
businesses, not countries. In other words,
69 of the biggest hundred economies are actually
individual corporations rather than nation
states. Um, is this something that should
push us in the direction of maybe thinking
about nation states and corporations more
similarly rather than completely distinguishing
them and evaluating nation states in a completely
different way than we evaluate corporations?
Because a lot of people will hear you and
I talking and they'll say, okay, but David,
just because a lot of big corporations planned
centrally in a way that seems to resemble
some of the ways in which countries have historically
had central planning doesn't mean that we
should interpret that central planning in
a similar way. Maybe the lines are a actually
a little bit blurrier there.
They're definitely blurrier. I mean, I think
there's still lots of, you know, there's still
lots of differences, but it really is, it's
an argument about, um, the scale of the planning,
uh, the complexity and really its ubiquity.
Um, I think we have to look at both, you know,
both that blurring of lines between nations
and corporations, but in general, looking
at our entire economic system, we have a line,
um, you know, our entire economic system and
what share of it is planned to what share
over this sort of already sort of subject
to conscious control. Um, we have a line from
Herbert Simon who was a, uh, an economist,
a Nobel Prize winner, um, most of the, you
know, pretty mainstream, um, economist. Um,
but he said he had this sort of thought experiment.
We said, imagine a Martian coming in, uh,
from outer space, uh, and looking down at
the earth first, um, and you know, and what,
and he drew two sort of pictures and he said,
you know what?
They see sort of green blobs connected by
thin red lines and the green blobs being areas
of planning and the red lines being sort of
market relationships or would they see, you
know, really a network of red lines with,
you know, specs of green. And he said it would
be the former. You'd really see if someone
was coming in and didn't really understand,
um, our social institutions if we sort of
looked at them with new, with new eyes, we'd
really see that there's these big centers
of economic planning throughout, you know,
how we produce and distribute everything from
healthcare to toothbrushes, you know, to,
to caterpillar machines to, to anything else.
Um, and they're connected by these thin red
lines of market relationships where it's the,
where's the centers of planning that are really
more important. Um, what if you look at the
economy, you know, with sort of fresh eyes
who doesn't end up exploited in this system?
Because I'm thinking, you know, we know about
the stories of employees and how they are
often a dependent on government subsidies
because wages are quite low. Working conditions
are not particularly good. And Amazon warehouses,
uh, often scheduling is a power dynamic where
the employee has relatively little control.
So we know about that. Uh, Walmart has huge
power to exploit suppliers where they say,
yeah, well now that we are 95% of your buying
a of your sales, we need you to reduce the
cost to us by 10% and now it's the supplier
that needs to figure out whether or how that's
even possible. In a sense, the government
is also actually exploited because they are
subsidizing the low wages of many of the employees
through social welfare programs, which if
the employees aren't higher wages, they wouldn't
have to like, it seems like it's basically
executives and shareholders who ended up getting
the majority of the gains.
Yeah. And I mean in a way, yes, because that's,
that's capitalism. That's capitalism. Right?
And that's capitalism baby. And that's how
it, that's how it works. I mean, in terms
of Walmart and Amazon specifically, you could
say that, you know, consumers get a bonus
because they get lower prices. But we have
to remember that, you know, as you said, you
know, consumers are also workers. They don't
have to be workers at Amazon or Walmart. They
might be workers at, at the suppliers. They
might be family members of, um, of workers.
You know, in a way the system is set up to,
um, produce things at low cost to lower, to
lower labor costs, to ignore, um, labor standards.
And I think the important thing for us is
who there's definitely conscious decision
making going on here. Um, you know, partly
it's a certain, it's a certain logic of the
economic system, but because of the degree
of planning, um, there are people who are
making decisions that we are going to do things
in this way.
And that's not the majority of us. It's who,
you know, it's who you said, sir, there was
this, the shareholders and executives. So
we have this shared capacity for decision
making. Um, and we think it's a normal thing
that we exercise, uh, this shared capacity
for decision making. Same the political sphere
where we now have, you know, representative
democracy. It's still very incomplete. And
there's, there's lots of problems with it,
but there's at least this notion that everyone
should be able to, to express their voice,
right? And it's often not as fully as, um,
as it can be. And it's, you know, especially
in the u s it's along racial lines where you
have lots of, uh, lots of, you know, flat
out discouragement of, um, of, of voting and
all of that. Um, but when we look at that
conomic sphere, that sort of, this sort of
idea that we have this shared capacity for
decision making and that we could be using
it together, kind of, you know, rationally,
again, plan and think about how, what goals
do you want to accomplish and how we want
to do that, um, really disappears.
What's the lowest hanging fruit in terms of
improvements that could be made? Because a
lot of the specific policy ideas that are
often mentioned, I find to basically be bandaid.
So when we talk about, well, you know, universal
basic income, Oh, that, that will help a lot
of people. It doesn't fundamentally change
the relationship between a lot of the players
in the system that we have a $15 minimum wage,
sort of similar analysis would apply a more
representation by trade unions may be, although
there are, you know, pros and cons to that.
What do you see as the most direct and simple
paths towards improving circumstances?
I mean, I think from the, from the perspective
of, um, of our book, I mean, I think things
like the Medicare for, for all campaign in
the u s which is, I mean different than in
other parts of parts of the world, which are,
they have sort of socialized medicine is an
important step. Um, because it says let's
take an entire sector of the economy, uh,
and let's actually subject it to more sort
of conscious planning, right? Let's, let's
take healthcare out of, out of the market.
And even though, again, even though the large
insurers and the large healthcare providers
are already internally planned, um, this level
of kind of social control and social decision
making over, over this system as a whole is
really limited. Um, you know, I'm, I'm up
in Canada. We already have, um, socialized
medicine, but it's very incomplete. We don't
have a pharmacare system. Again, it's another
huge area of the economy, um, where corporations
are making huge profits, providing, uh, you
know, a, a very socially useful and necessary
good that isn't, um, socialized. We have huge
issues with childcare where again, that's
another whole sector of the economy that could
be, um, taken out of the market and sort of
you commodify. So I think part of this solution
is taking areas, these are the larger areas
of the economy. Um, and making the case for
saying, let's actually do the planning in
a democratic, in a democratic, yeah.
Wait, the book is called the People's Republic
of Walmart. We've been speaking with the books
author me called Rise War Ski. So thank you
so much for talking to us about this. Really
important. Thanks so much for having me on